[Music]
according to that dusty old Constitution
only Congress can declare a war
thankfully presidents willing to step up
and look past delegated authority have
gotten our military involved in Korea
Bosnia Syria Somalia just to name a few
in fact the executive branch is now more
powerful and autonomous than ever before
that's why we at DARPA have created a
new tool to help presidents wield the
power they've already taken
we call it the crown system the cranial
response online weapons Network place
snugly on the President's head the
Crown's redundant array of wireless
transmitters sends real-time impulses
straight to the national security
apparatus bypassing the overly
complicated need for debate or national
unity gold-plated for excellent
conductivity and corrosion resistance
the crown looks great on a man or a
woman erecting these fashionable signal
repeaters in every major city in America
will not only create a robust network
infrastructure for the crown system but
it also serves as a constant reminder
that our president loves us and has
everything under control
with the addition of the integrated
smart chair and the handheld control
interface the crown system is fully
suitable to handle non-military
applications as well politically
expedient recess appointments
withholding information from Congress
rewriting legislation directing federal
departments to ignore existing law wage
and price controls suspending habeas
corpus putting japanese-americans in
internment camps it's all there at the
flip of a switch it even comes with a
cave cuz [ __ ] Congress the crown system
from DARPA giving presidents the tools
they need to wield the power they've
already taken
you